hey what is up guys i'm kvhd here and
i'm in las vegas for ces 2015 and if
you've been following the show at all or
if you've been paying attention to the
news you've probably heard of a little
something called quantum dot technology
in tvs if you haven't heard of it that's
okay too we're gonna break it down so
despite the name quantum dot isn't
really all that insane it's essentially
just an improved backlighting technology
so with the led and lcd tvs we have now
the backlight is this pure white light
that gets shined through but white light
isn't just red green and blue white
light is red green blue some yellows
some purple some other colors and that
needs to be filtered before it goes
through as those rgb pixels and that
filtering will take away a little bit of
light a little bit of vividness what
quantum dot backlighting promises is to
not need that filtering so it'll shine
pure red green and blue light through
and it'll appear to be pure white but it
won't require any of that filtering that
an led or lcd backlight does and that'll
make it a little bit of a brighter image
and a much more efficient picture so of
course i had to take a look at these at
the show floor at ces and i found
samsung's new su hd tvs these are all
quantum dot tvs and they made these big
bold claims about showing a wider color
gamut and being much brighter and much
more efficient and technically these
claims are correct though you might not
be able to see this difference with
normal content or games unless you have
it side by side with a normal lcd
backlit tv but these quantum dot tvs
look good nevertheless don't get me
wrong not insanely great or anything but
definitely very bright and very vivid
but it's still no oled display you can
definitely tell when something is an
oled display oh led panels like we've
seen in a lot of tvs here and also a lot
of phones don't require any backlighting
at all so all the individual pixels are
creating their own light it's not as
bright as a backlight but it's also a
little bit more efficient because when
you want to create black you just don't
like the pixel at all and that creates
these super dark inky blacks and awesome
contrast ratios it's beautiful and it's
the future of television so we have oled
displays already in a lot of our
smartphones will we ever see quantum dot
displays in our smartphones too i would
say yes maybe not this year or anything
but it makes perfect sense considering
one it's more efficient than lcds and
that would be great for battery life and
two it's much brighter because of the
lack of filtration which means outdoor
visibility will be much better and
that's where we use our phones anyway
it's just a matter of getting the
technology small enough to fit in a
smartphone and fit in our pocket so
that's essentially it quantum dot is
what's going to start showing up on tv
stickers in a best buy near you it's not
something super insane like the name
might imply it's some physics trick but
is it legit absolutely it legitimately
allows for brighter and more efficient
display panels thanks to improved
backlighting is it new
actually no the idea has been around
since the 1990s but for the past two
years there have been quantum dot
backlit displays available on the market
they're just now getting that fancy
branding and su hd sticker from samsung
so here at ces 2015 this is where it
gets branded it now has a sexy buzz term
alongside 4k
curved
3d
flexible
quantum dot now you know thanks for
watching i'll talk to you guys in the
next one
peace